[Music]
it is wednesday and time for our morning
cup of joe with metro sheriff joe
lombardo good morning to you sheriff
thanks for being with us
hi alex good to see you good to see you
too sheriff election day it's less than
a week away now
will metro have extra patrols at voting
sites there will be a few in person that
day
uh yes of course we will but when you
say
add voting sites it's it's a little bit
more complicated than that
it's important for us to not to show any
authority in close
close proximity to those sites we will
be aware exactly where all the voting
sites are
we will provide extra patrol to ensure
that the security
and any person that intends to disrupt
them so we have a quick response but we
will be out of sight out of sound
hopefully
so people don't feel oppressed i guess
so the past few months there have been
different issues we've reported on
during the pandemic
of party houses and other short-term
rentals that have been getting kind of
rowdy
so how can residents report those issues
and can action be taken
yeah you know it's unfortunately we've
had some pretty significant crimes
associated with a lot of those not a lot
of them a few of those rentals
to include murder or homicide and
it's it's important for us to become
aware of that
as the police department and to address
the concern if you are a neighbor
and we want you as a community member
and as a neighbor to be able to reach
out to us
and ask for assistance to deal with that
problem even if it's not occurring then
making us aware of it so you can either
go to the substation get online go to
the substation do a service request
or you can call 3-1-1 if the event is
not occurring now to make us aware of
that so we can
address it prior to or you can call
9-1-1
if it is occurring in its immediacy and
we can respond hopefully
an appropriate amount of time halloween
it is coming up on
saturday of course things are a lot
different this year including
trick-or-treating
what is metro preparing for do you have
any new concerns this year
do you have a costume i i
have you seen my shark costume i was
sent sheriff
i heard about it yes it is quite the
spectacle
for your info i don't have a costume
okay
you can take the shark if you'd like
it'd probably fit you a little better
the uh you know halloween's going to be
i don't know it's going to be weird this
year you know
dealing with the proximity of the
pandemic and how kids are
willing to accept gifts from people that
want to hand out candy and
just the whole thing is unfortunate it's
going to be a weird experience for our
children
people have to be careful on every
halloween for people that are intending
to cause harm
obviously we need to sanitize things
post
receiving of the of that candy
and just a general awareness of what is
occurring
all right well thank you so much for
joining us sheriff lombardo and happy
halloween
hope you have a good weekend all right
you too alex thank you
and if you have a question for sheriff
lombardo send it to us on our website
it's 8newsnow.com
find out if your question was answered
every wednesday